welcome back it's the man to my right
the executive producer of religionist
sports right here on audience season 3
premiered a few Wednesday's ago
and it airs every single Wednesday night
at a Eastern time his shutup and dribble
with LeBron James on Showtime premiered
early last month and the man whose
religion to sports media companies
co-founder with Tom Brady and Michael
strand is here Gotham Chopra good to see
you brother
thanks for having me what does it like
to work with all these big-time athletes
man I mean I'm lucky I mean look it's a
it's sort of a dream come true my wife
always jokes is like wait so are we
getting paid are you getting paid or you
thing to do this because I got to ride
today AFC Championship last year with
Tom Brady and and yeah so I mean it's a
lot of fun it's they set a high bar you
know right for sure but we dive an
amazing team that you know works on all
these shows again you was that part of
Tom versus time at the time where you
were shooting Brady flying to the AFC
championship game right it was driving
it was when he you know he it was the
AFC against the Jags right he had cut
his hand nobody quite knew the severity
of it um but yeah I mean it was me with
a camera that's what it came down to at
the end we started with documentary
crews and boom Mike's it gradually
became as the season went on and he
really you know focused on football he
just was like he calls me gee yeah he's
like gee if you want to come and ride
great but I'm not doing that that crew
thing so what do you mean so you were
not with a camera at the time no I was I
was literally shooting it myself that
was the only way that he would allow you
to shoot anything as if it was you not
the crew thing yeah okay so when did you
first meet him when Tom for like he used
to have a home out here during the
offseason five or six years ago and
probably when I first met him and had to
accent my professional because I was a
huge Patriots fan I've been a huge
patron right my whole life growing up
and so when I met him he had a home in
Brentwood rice started getting to know
him that's kind of when religion of
sports conceptually started so he was in
on the ground floor so to speak and
we'll get into that in a second your
success with Tom versus time and
Facebook watch is there any possibility
that your continued
do that a little bit more with Tom at
all no I think you know trying to spin
it off into subsequent seasons turns it
into a reality show I think part of what
made it cool was the scarcity of it
right you'd never done it before and I
don't know if he'll ever do anything
like that again but don't you think that
the what's still to come is potentially
the most fascinating part of the story
would you not agree with that as a
storyteller I think so yeah I am and you
know look Tom's now people he's on
social media he's sort of documenting a
lot of this in real time himself and I'm
still you know I'm I was with Tom on
Sunday just you know more as a friend
and and but but I think you know he's
just so that was a unique moment in time
it felt like turning 40 and everything
and I just I don't know that he wants to
do it again and did you text him that I
want him to call in right now did I
think josh mcdaniels has other plans for
him he's in practice he's in practice
what's going on with the Patriots
practicing in the middle of an afternoon
for we prior to going to Miami
Chris big game they're doing their job
big game doing the job all right but
there's still a you're there's still a
Dumb and Dumber chance your phone rings
in the middle of this conversation good
happen okay very good your success with
fake Facebook watch is that what led you
to LeBron or vice versa or well no I
mean I've known the Brawn mostly
maverick Carter actually I've known for
years and this project has sort of been
two years in the making and then they
call these things unscripted for a
reason
you know it changed over time as the
sort of world around has changed like
what do you mean I mean it what started
out as was gonna be equal parts
basketball and sort of pop culture and
all this stuff and politics the politics
piece the social saloon laura ingraham
changed everything when she told how to
shut up and do it was kind of trending
in that direction she gave a great title
I'm very grateful to her but you know
it's Colin Kaepernick in some ways that
changed it right like it's just part of
what we talk about in every aspect of
our lives right now is politics right
and LeBron you know it certainly wasn't
just because this project he's been out
there outspoken about issues opening a
school in Akron and stuff like that
right just felt like that was the right
thing to focus on so I mean you heard
what Duran had to say right what do you
think of when you hear that is
buddy who obviously is part a business
partner of LeBron James you know him you
see him that he calls the environment
around him because of the media that has
come to him or wants to cover him and
that it's all about him even though it's
not his fault he's saying I don't know
about toxic I don't think he he's not
wrong in terms of like LeBron is a
special personality and he's been doing
this in some ways since he was 14 years
old he's so good at it just in terms of
like interacting with the media and I
think he's magnetic in that way I've
also noticed like just working with all
these guys they're so alpha not just on
the court but off the court so I can see
how a guy like KD whose every bit the
player right now that you know LeBron is
today yes I you know like does he need
to share the room so to speak I think he
and Steph have a very you know special
relationship because there's such
different types of personalities annoy
and Steph is a very sort of a unique
personality but I could see that I mean
you know cadiz he's out for himself
so do you think that LeBron is gonna
have trouble attracting people I know
that this is not your area of expertise
but you're around him you around him
Eric I mean I don't think I think LeBron
first of all first of all you don't need
arguably the best player on in the
league and KD to sort of make you a
championship team LeBron's pretty good
himself I think there are other players
that will be attracted I mean it's LA
it's LeBron LeBron makes players better
yeah I don't I don't know I mean you're
talking to a guy who by the way hates
the Lakers I mean I like LeBron but like
I'm a Celtics fan is LeBron aware of
this yeah this is how me and Kobe got
along so well because actually Kobe's so
combative that he loved the fact that
you know he was collaborating with a
Celtics fan yes as we could fight all
day and debate all day about it right
yeah so are you gonna do something with
Kyrie I mean I mean what a way to act
out your fans kind of feel like I need
to do something actually would like
Derek Jeter like I also sort of you know
I worked with Victor Cruz a couple years
ago Patriots fan and that was not easy
but
it's it's it's behind enemy lines very
thick a Gotham Chopra here on the Rich
Eisen show how do you choose the subject
matter for religion of sports I mean we
just saw radio audience we just saw on a
TV only segment the clip of
motorcyclists essentially yeah zipping
down some road course on the Isle of Man
how do you know about this stuff how do
you choose yeah you know fortunately now
we're in our third seasons we've
established a bit of a brand and with
our partners here at 18 TN and so we
have people approaching us we have a
great research team that has built it
almost like a catalog you know depending
on the season and where we are but we're
really looking at these sort of obscure
you know the whole ideas why sports
matter in these communities in these
nooks and crannies of the planet and you
know something like this which if you're
a sports fan you're kind of what you may
have heard about just and it just sort
of timed out for us and then you're
finding it these things are all
character-driven you really have to find
the people also that make these stories
come alive so we've been lucky but we
now have filmmakers we have producers
door you know editors etc reaching out
saying have you heard about this thing
and in this obscure part of the planet
where this weapons what would you want
to do I mean give me give me a spot
something you haven't covered yet that's
something you you think would be
fascinating or somebody haven't shown
here I'm I'm interested in cricket I
worked on a cricket project many years
ago at an ESPN but in a way I want to do
it all over again you have these
rivalries between like India and
Pakistan I mean this isn't just like
we're talking geopolitical fun I mean it
takes red sox-yankees you know I would
say to a whole nuclear level like
literally yeah so I think there's like
those types of things I think there's a
bottomless well of like soccer stories
around the planet and I think some of
those are really interesting so well I
mean do you are you concerned that stuff
like that doesn't translate to an
American audience because you're talking
about cricket you're talking about
something I mean we've always been like
we love I'm a hardcore sports fan but
we've always been about like these are
stories that go beyond just sports fan
and it's really about people and
characters and like why do these things
matter so much Martin so I think the
sport sometimes is the backdrop but it's
really I mean motorcycle racing you know
most of us don't care about that but
it's like these people are willing to
put their lives on the line absolutely
that's the thing that gets you in Gotham
Chopra executive producer again of
eighties religion in sports you could
watch it on audience Network channel 239
every single Wednesday at 8:00 Eastern
Time and unshut up and dribble with
LeBron James on Showtime it premiered
November 3rd what's coming up on the
next version of that what do you have
for me on the future of that show here
on know shut up and dribble well shut up
and rules a limited series that was
three parts on Showtime
billiards it it's you can get Showtime
anytime it's not I'm saying it's such a
three people you're not gonna do more
more dribbling or I mean look we live in
some interesting times probably yeah I'd
love to do more you know I think and
LeBron certainly has a lot more to say
plus he's you know what's cool about
LeBron is he's he's enabled a generation
of you so you guys you have guys like
Jalen Brown you know you have draymond
Green who are now they come into the
league like this is what there's they're
supposed to be outspoken and you have a
commissioner and Adam silver who's very
supportive of that right well it's good
to see you man yeah thanks for coming on
here tell Tom when he does text you back
that on behalf of slow Michigan men
everywhere thank you anything moving
like a zephyr window I know it's pretty
amazing like a zephyr wind is not a bad
fantasy football name and you got brady
taking a knee taking a victory formation
and pointing at the spot of the football
is your avatar I think that'd be a good
one at Gotham Chopra on Twitter again
religion is sports season three
Wednesday nights at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Time thanks for coming on brother thanks
you got absolutely anytime the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience